hello everyone and welcome to what is
probably the best game that was played
yesterday in the skilling open knockout
section
it's wesley's over system or a job of
and it it's the third third game between
the two of them
uh first game was won by rajabo with the
black pieces second game ended in a draw
and this is now the third one it's
really really an awesome game a lot of
you have already suggested it
uh so let's dive straight into it wesley
has the white piece and he really needs
a win to bounce back in this match
opens with c4 so the english opening is
on the board
sorry about that uh and we have e5 uh
sorry not e5 knight to f6 by rajabov uh
we have knight to c3 e5
and now knight to f3 and knight to c6 so
the four knights opening
uh of the of the english with e3 uh and
now
bishop to b for challenging this knight
bishop to c2
that's a queen obviously queen to c2
defending
uh and now castles by black and here
knights to d5 and while it looks like
maybe you can double up white spawns
problem is after this knight moves
then this pawn is no longer defended so
instead we have brook to e8
now the pawn is defended but now queen
to f5 and again uh what do you play here
uh if you go knight captures on d5 now
to double the pawns you don't really uh
you don't really gain all that much uh
uh because after captures and knight e7
you're just gonna go with queen captures
an e5 so
uh it's it's the same stuff so here
d6 challenging the queen now defending
the e5 pawn
and here knight captures an f6 with the
jerk so here we have a
a very very quick queen trade but uh
this game is extremely wild even without
queen so captures captures and captures
and here
a3 challenging the bishop and this is
all very standard theory of this uh
line in this uh english opening because
there are over 100 games in the database
with this exact same
position from uh top tier tournament
play
uh with bishop back to c5 and now b4
grabbing more space on the queen side
bishop to b6 luckily your bishop cannot
be trapped as this pawn guards the c5
square and the bishop to b2 now
wesley continues developing and here uh
most of the games in the database
continue with pawn to a5 but here
at a job of place a6 and uh it is as of
move 12 that we have a completely new
game
so this is basically where where our
game starts uh we have queen side castle
by white preparing d4 at some point
and bishop to f5 now this bishop is
going to be uh
going to be really awesome here uh
controlling this entire diagonal not
allowing
the the white king to go king to b1 and
white needs to be very careful here
and here you could continue with
something like d4 right away you could
start developing your bishop but here we
have rook to g1
probably probably with the idea that
maybe at some point you can play g for
g5 and open up the g file with your with
your dark square bishop controlling this
diagonal
could be useful at some point uh so here
knight back the e7 nice regarding the d5
and the f5
squares and finally d4 now by white
with bishop to e4 and now comes
knight to d2 challenging the bishop here
we have bishop back to g6
and now comes knight back to f3 c5 here
looks very strong but
of course the black will not capture and
allow uh well
this bishop to be uh blocked out of the
game because just bishop a7 and now
although this could be fine for white uh
in a rapid game
you don't know if you've maybe over
extended a a
a little too much and will you be able
to hold everything together so here
knight back to f3 uh and we have a5
uh busting open the queen side now as
the king is on the queen side
you you want to have some files open for
your rook so of course
uh wesley uh prevents that he goes to b5
and now
c6 so the java now will try to open up
the c file
uh we have a4 captures here and now a
captures on b5 keeping the c
file closed uh but there's a problem as
for the moment you have a backwards
c4 pawn and it's not going to be
it's not going to be all that pleasant
so here a4
a very important move as it uh well
prepares a3 but also
opens up the dark square bishop for this
diagonal and with the dark square bishop
on this diagonal and the light square
bishop on this diagonal
you can see that the white king doesn't
have all that many squares
to go to so here bishop to a3 stopping
this pawn from going any further
and now e captures on d4 we have
captures
and now a beautiful beautiful uh a
signature
a job of move knight to d5 a brilliant
sacrifice
that really shows just how powerful the
position is from black's perspective
because if you capture the knight rook 8
to c8 is just
crushing because the bishop still
controls this diagonal you have to go to
b2 now rook c2 check
king to b1 and now this rook the d2
check
checking the king attacking the rook and
if you want to defend the rook king c1
now comes rook to a2
and now the bishop is attacked the
bishop still slices all the way here and
there is no good defense against rook
the c8 which just
ends the game so this is what would
happen uh should uh should wesley accept
the knight sacrifice so here uh for the
moment the knight
is is immortal uh we have king to b2 and
now comes
bishop to a5 here rajab again
offers the knight but still the the
knight cannot be captured if you capture
it now
or rather you you can capture it but
after rookie the c8 it's
uh very very hard to spot uh
how how you will deal with this the
bishop pair is still fully operational
you could go for something like rook to
c1 but after captures and captures at
the other rook coming to c8 it's still
going to be
uh incredibly difficult for for white to
play this there is
one move that actually allows you to
capture on d5 but it's uh very hard to
find
captures and then after rook 8 the c8
you go rook to d3
and now you've blocked the light square
bishop you don't allow this uh
rook to come to c2 but still it's uh uh
difficult to find difficult to cut of
course i do imagine wesley thought of it
but it's very hard to calculate and you
don't know what's happening the rook
will come to c4
you're gonna double up on the c file and
it's just very tricky playing against
the bishop pair when you are low on time
so here instead we have bishop captures
on d6 grabbing that d6 spawn
but now just knight to c3 challenging
the rook here
rook to c1 and now knight to e4 and
again
what do you play here is white the the
bishop is under attack the f2 pawn is
under attack
so here bishop back to g3 uh stopping
both threats and now
uh well you could play something like
bishop to b4 to just prepare a3
uh rajab plays it right away and this is
just beautiful
uh you don't want to capture the pawn if
you capture bishop d2 opens up a
discovered check wins the rook on c1
so here after a3 check king the a2 was
played by wesley
and now comes knight to c3 with check
forcing the the king to capture the pawn
uh or you you don't capture you can go
something like king to beat you but then
it's just uh
then it's just weird you allow this past
pawn to go
all the way to a2 and then it's going to
be very hard
so here king captures an a3 it is in
fact the the top move recommended by the
engine
and now comes bishop to b4 with check
now rajab of sacrifice is a bishop
for some very sneaky play and the bishop
must be captured
because everything else ends in uh not
just a checkmate but but
such a remarkable checkmate that i will
have to show it for example king b3
if you decline the sacrifice you get
knights to a2
attacking the rook and the bishop here
and now if you want to keep everything
together let's say rook to a1
uh rook to a3 with check king to b2
and now bishop to c3 with check
sacrificing the rook here only move as
the bishop covers
this diagonal and the knight covers c1
is to capture the rook
and now the incredible bishop the c2 now
the bishop
pair controls uh these four squares and
there is no defense against the rook the
a8 checkmate
uh you can capture the knight but still
rook t8 is checkmate as the bishop pair
is not allowing the king to go anywhere
it's not a completely forced line uh
it only happens if the rule goes to a1
but i i just showed it
for you to see what what is possible
here but
every line is completely losing for
black for white if you play it like this
so here king captures on b4 it is the
only move that
allows white not to lose and now knight
to 82 with
check and here wesley has to decide what
to do and
the point is he's very low on time i
think he was around 20 seconds on the
clock here maybe even lower
and he needs to decide whether to go
king to b3 or king to c5
and here wesley played king to c5 saying
that
uh okay maybe maybe i can do some damage
here the thing uh
if he went king to b3 then it's fine but
it's very hard to find and
when i say fine i mean uh possible
possible to defend because here after
knight captures on c1 king b2
knight goes to e2 only square if you
don't want to lose the knight but now
after captures and captures with
check king b3 you get to rook a to a2
and it's still a very
ugly position to play uh black is up the
exchange but white has this massive pawn
pawn chain here so it's going to be it's
going to be pretty crazy
however after this knight to 82 check
wesley said you can have the rook i'm
playing king c5 i'm gonna play king b6
i'm gonna capture this pawn here
i'm gonna have three connected past
pawns and with the bishop covering the
b8 square i don't have to
worry about your rooks checking me from
the eighth rank however
this is now completely losing as rajabov
is on the move
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for a job of
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
uh finishing this game in great style
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
it's rook to e6 and now uh there is
nothing more for you to play here uh
you've cut off the king completely the
king cannot come to
uh here the knight guards that square
the rook covers uh
the entire sixth rank and now well the
b6 is just too big of a threat for
example if you play something like rook
to a1
just b6 check king d5 and now everything
is checkmate
knight c3 is checkmate knight b for his
checkmate bishop to e4 is checkmate you
can you know choose your checkmate
everything is checkmate it's i mean this
is crazy
like all of these moves are our
checkmate it's uh not not
very often that you will see something
like this so of course wesley said okay
i cannot allow b6 so he played b6
himself now black cannot play b6
but now instead of winning in three
moves uh arajava can win in one move and
i'm sure you'll see it without even
pausing the video
uh rook to a5 and this is now checkmate
uh so it was made in one but uh whatever
wesley played it would be
it would be incredibly difficult to
defend so knight covers this
this uh entire fifth rank is covered
sixth rank is covered and the king has
nowhere to go so a very nice rook a5
checkmate
on move 31. uh the after this rook to e6
you could continue to struggle with
something like
bishop to d6 it allows you to kind of
prolong
the game but it's only prolonging it
it's not nothing serious and of course
white will still lose
so incredible game by rajab of
constantly offering that knight on e5
and as this is already the second game
he won in the match so from three games
uh two wins by rajabo one game is a draw
uh the first match is won by the jabba
so wesley will get his chance to counter
back
in today's match uh and we'll see how it
goes and we're just gonna
show the standings here so these are the
results of uh
yesterday's clashes let me just make
that a little bit bigger
so magnus carlsen defeated anishigiri
after three draws he was able to win
one game i thought about showing it but
uh it was
it was a pretty boring game and
especially since uh
they played the italian game and the
gear did not go for the evan's game but
i decided
you know best not to show it uh levin
aren't undefeated yani ponnichi with two
and a half
to one and a half uh rajabov defeated
wesley so two and a half to half as only
three games were played
and maxine vashilagraw was uh better
than hikaru nakamura winning the first
game then nakamura had
had a chance to bounce back but uh
maxime defended well and
uh he won the match so we're gonna see
what happens today
will we see uh will we see uh you know
the
the the people who lost to come back
into the match or will it be
a one-sided uh one-sided uh brawl
uh so yeah that's uh that's the game i
do hope you guys enjoyed it like i said
a lot of you have requested it
and for a very good reason says it is a
beautiful attacking game always uh
always nice to see a job of crushing
everyone with the black pieces it's it's
definitely his style
uh i would like to thank soria bodat
peter paul vasa klaus muller nielsen
uh jonathan money and clayton miller for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the knockouts checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day